M: have you tried using this on your face
O: not yet
M: okay good did you ever feel the urge to
O: yes
M: why
O: because i like destroying my face
O: hi this is omar from lab muffin
beauty science i'm not a phd in chemistry
i am not a skincare nerd and apparently some of
you might be horrified by my old skincare routine
M: i'm sure many of you might have someone in your
life like a partner your mum your dad your sister
your brother who just has the worst skincare
routine and i mean a lot of people are genetically
blessed and generally they're fine with a frankly
trash hot skincare routine but sometimes there is
just some things that just don't quite sit well
with your spirit they kind of mess up your chakras
your aura gets a bit tainted so today i thought
i'd talk about some products that might help
ease them into good skin care habits that don't
destroy your faith in all that is good and holy
M: this video is sponsored by necessaire and the
reason i came up with this idea is because this
is actually the one product that's in both our
showers and it's sort of like the product that
got him out of this awful routine i've eased
him into a bunch of other products as well
there's another necessaire product in there
but first let's talk about what you used to do
O: so six months ago my skincare routine was
quite literally just this and tresemme shampoo
i used to use the shampoo not just on my hair but
all over my body when i ran out of the soap and um
used to use the soap on my armpits my back my face
just hot swapping really whatever i had available
M: hot swapping?
O: hot swapping
M: so omar is a bit of a hard sell when it
comes to skin care because he doesn't really
have many major skin problems and when he does
get a pimple he actually enjoys digging it out
O: yep
M: so i found what works
for omar is a good gimmick
O: yep
M: utility packaging
M: and minimal skin feel afterwards
O: absolutely
M: so obviously the first thing we had to
fix was the soap and shampoo on your face
O: what was wrong with that
M: so let's start with the soap the reason i
went for the necessaire body wash is because
it is pretty much formulated like a face product
so this has the utility packaging which omar
loves it has a screw top the top doesn't come off
and so you don't drop it it's very easy to use
for a bottle product especially in the shower
O: this twisty twisty top should be
included in all products love this
M: this has a pretty nice scent it's unisex it's
light it leaves your skin pretty moisturized
unlike the bar soap if you want to
stock up on more of these magical
twist tops you can use the code
labmuffin10 for 10% off necessaire
M: okay so bar soap
for those of you who don't know is made of really
long surfactants so surfactants are the molecules
that clean your skin they have an end that likes
water and an end that likes oil so if you have
the two of them in the one package the oily end
latches onto the oil on your skin and then the
watery end helps the oil dissolve into water
the problem with soap is that its surfactants
are really long and narrow and that means they get
into your skin a lot more easily and they irritate
and they also have a charged head which also adds
to the irritation so out of all of the surfactants
that are commonly in skincare products bar soaps
have the worst in terms of irritation and dryness
M: another reason bar soap is bad is because
it tends to have a really high ph now on your
body that tends to be okay because your
body has thicker skin some parts of your
body also has a higher pH so armpits for
example and groin actually have higher pH
which means that soap isn't quite as
bad but on your face this is one of
those things that can lead to more acne your
face likes to be at a low pH at a higher pH
acne bacteria actually grow better you're
thinking about squeezing pimples now aren't you
O: yep
M: so that's why we don't like bar soap on our
faces now shampoo is - depends on the shampoo
sometimes they're actually okay for your face
shampoos typically have a higher concentration of
surfactants because your hair has a higher surface
area than your face the more concentrated it is
the more cleaning power it has and so shampoos
are kind of like really concentrated cleansers
O: so can i talk about why i
started using shampoo go on
so i grew up thinking that i should be
shampooing my hair every time i had a shower
and around the age of 13 i started needing
more than one shower per day because i have
a shower in the morning and a shower
in the afternoon after playing sports
so i'd be showering twice a day occasionally i
run out of soap i'd run a body wash and you know i
ended up using shampoo on the rest of my body and
at one point i put on my face and it felt amazing
M: what do you mean by amazing
O: dry
M: so there's another problem we have omar likes
that dry tight feeling and a lot of people do
because they don't realize what it means
is that your skin is getting warped
O: feels clean
M: skin's getting warped
O: okay
M: so the dry tight feeling is
actually surfactants going in
and messing up the shape of
the proteins in your skin
O: right
M: when they change shape that's
what gives the tight feeling and
as you can imagine proteins changing shape on
your skin is not a good thing for your skin
O: right
M: so this has surfactants that are commonly
found in face products as well which is why i'm
comfortable giving this to omar because
he can use it on his face and it's not
that bad um in fact it's actually fine so on
top of having nice gentle surfactants this
also has glycerin which is hydrating it also
has niacinamide so we're sneaking some actives
into his routine as well and so hopefully this
leaves your skin feeling hydrated and not tight
even though you like the tight feeling but you'll
get used to not having the tight feeling i promise
M: okay so onto omar's pimples this is the
main pimple treatment you were using before
O: yes this this is good
M: show me what you did to your pimp show it
show the class what you did to your pimples
before before
O: um i feel like i'm about to get i
feel i'm about to get made fun of here
M: all right so here is a mole um
show us how you would squeeze that
O: so what i would do is i'll take these
tweezers and i just put that on the other
side of each side of the pimple and then push
and then slightly squeeze and it pops right up
M: slightly squeeze
O: slightly squeeze for me
M: you were putting your whole
back into it i've seen you
O: a little bit of blood
doesn't really affect much
M: so obviously we needed to make sure omar
didn't get pimples and that's why we introduced
the necessaire scrub and an exfoliating towel
O: so this this i love i've got oily
skin and i get pimples on my back
all the time and it's hard to reach
and this made a massive difference
feels nice i feel soft afterwards i
use it weekly i've got a weekly routine
M: you do
O: my one complaint is where's the
twisty top come on where's the twisty top
this is like a screw top twisty top would be nice
M: so i think the reason they don't have
the twisty top is because this scrub
this actually contains particles
this has bamboo charcoal and pumice
and so the little bits might actually get
stuck in the twisty top i assume that's why
M: so originally i tried to make him use a
leave-on chemical exfoliant especially on his back
O: no no
M: i tried to get him to use the paula's choice
bha which is one of my favorites for
my face um he doesn't like it why not
O: nup feels like imagine putting vinegar or
soy sauce on your skin it just
turns sticky and who'd want that
M: people who like clear skin
O: just feels off and weird
M: so yeah skin care favorite for us um apparently
just doesn't work with some people um i also gave
him the spray version and again like even though
that was more convenient it was still sticky
O: nup nup bleh
M: i also tried this which
you were actually okay with
O: yeah but you have to do it
M: yeah so the dr dennis gross peels um the nice
thing about these they are really expensive though
the nice thing about them is you can sort
of get a whole bunch of uses out of one so
one of these is enough to do both our faces and
both our backs it's also a lot less sticky than
the paula's choice version i think the stridex
pads are also quite non-sticky as well so that
might also be an option but again it's a little
bit harder to get to your back whereas if you
have a scrub combined with an exfoliating towel
then your person can do their back themselves
M: so another nice option i think for people who
tend to use their body products on their face
is the dove cream beauty bar so this looks like
a soap but it's not actually a soap they use
um surfactants that aren't soap surfactants
and they it has a lower ph so a lot of soaps
um those surfactants only work at higher ph so
this has the gentler surfactants and the lower
ph so this makes it fine for your face one of
the issues some people say is that it breaks
them out because of the creamy ingredients
um but if it doesn't break you out then this
is actually one of the few bar soap looking
products you can use on your face without worrying
M: so this is another product i gave to
omar it's the fenty cleans'r and this
is actually the only cleanser he uses
because what do you like most about it
O: the twisty top! so this is my actual
bottle that i'm using in the shower um so
it's still a bit wet so what i like about this
product is that this is the goods twisty top
made a massive difference in my skin makes
my skin makes my face feel amazing especially
compared to soap yes um less breakouts
and compared to shampoo this is way better
M: why is it better
O: because it's less aggressive
M: little bubbles
O: little bubbles oh bubbles
M: do you like the bubbles
O: i like the bubbles i also
like the foaminess of this
um it does foam up very nicely on my skin
makes me feel like i'm cleaning my skin
M: now onto sun protection now one of the reasons
i didn't give oma a chemical exfoliant even though
that is often recommended for beginners
is because he doesn't wear daily sunscreen
and one of the things with telling
people to use chemical exfoliants
without daily sunscreen is that it often
ends badly it's so much harder to start
someone on a sunscreen than it is to
start someone on a chemical exfoliant
now on to your sun protection this was
your sunscreen tell me when you used it
O: right so i used this when the
uv rating was higher than 10 and
i was going out for a long walk or i was
going to the beach and gonna go swimming
so i typically only use this on my face if
i was going on a walk um and if i was at the
beach and taking on my shirt and going into
the water then i'd use this all over my body
M: so what was stopping you from using this
more regularly because you go on walks a lot
O: yeah it's mainly because i'm mainly trying to
prevent myself from being sunburned on my face
so that was the main reason um
besides that it's really sticky
not very nice texture on my skin or on my
hands i hate it on my hands um that's it
M: so being a sunscreen hoarder
i gave omar a whole bunch of
sunscreens that he could try out tell
me what you thought of each of these
O: this i didn't like i don't like mousse of
my skin i don't like that feeling of putting
like whipped cream on on a surface and trying to
spread it around it's so awkward i don't like this
and the cap nah utility is a
big thing for me don't like it
M: yeah so i actually thought omar would like this
because it's long lasting it sinks into your skin
and after it's sunken on you can actually wash
your skin with a bit of water and it's still fine
but apparently the film that's left on
your skin afterwards still was too much
it does leave a little bit of a film
because that's how it stays for so long
O: nah hate it
O: azclear smells like something
is on fire when it shouldn't be it
also leaves a residue on my skin don't
like that and what's with the flip top
you know if i put this in my backpack it's
going to explode everywhere nup don't like it
M: so as much as we like to think everyone is
fine with fragrance free a lot of people are not
and yeah these are all things
that i never even thought
of considering when it came to recommending
you a sunscreen so interesting data collection
O: biore now i like this one uh i this
is the second from the top for me um
it's really it's really nice and uh light on
my skin it gives me spf 50 which is really good
M: 50 plus
O: 50 plus has a twist top which is
okay pretty good won't be worried about
exploding my backpack um and smells nice so
this i would use but it's not my favorite
O: this however is my favorite
and this is la roche-posay
this one it meets all the marks of my favorite
sunscreen because uh it's nice and thin
uh light doesn't leave a residue doesn't and
it smells nice um actually does its job with
protecting my skin and the utility okay so it's
not the twisty thing that you know necessaire
has but nice screw top here i'm not afraid of
it exploding my backpack this this is the goods
M: so how do you feel with your new routine
O: i have a weekly routine
M: do you feel like a changed man
O: i feel like i actually care
about my skin and this is weird
so my skin has gotten better i have a weekly
routine now and my skin's gotten better
M: how's it gotten better
O: less pimples
M: mmm
O: and you know less dryness less everything it's
just normal skin which is basically what i want
i don't really care about pigmentation don't
really care about you know scabs or anything
else like that i don't really care but it's
gotten better it's less annoying that's me
M: so i feel like that is a win high five
O: high five yeah
M: this is omar's routine before
and this is omar's routine after
O: bior biore-yi la roche per se la roche posay
M: oh my gosh
O: i don't really like mousse mouse
mousse what's this called again
M: tweezers